aber trotzdem gibt es ja auch Probleme
Hier und Jetzt und da glaube ich
tatsächlich dass die die
Moralisierung von allem und jedem zur
der schlechten politischen Stimmung der
vergangenen Jahre wahnsinnig beigetragen
hat es hat also es gab schon vorher aber
ganz doll angefangen hat es in der
corona-krise also als wir permanent
belehrt wurden also nicht darüber wie
man seine Hände wäscht und so sondern
mit mit so Fersen wie meine Disziplin
ist unsere beste Medizin also was mich
immer ans Pionier Gelöbnis erinnert hat
auf groß Plakaten bespaßt wurden
Bescheid wurden von der von der
Bundesregierung damals noch große
Koalition das geht jetzt so weiter zum
Beispiel mit zwei Riesen Kampagnen
einmal das Wirtschaftsministeriums und
dann das Gesundheitsministeriums die
darüber informieren der Winter kommt es
wird kalt man kann sich anstecken man
kann sich erkälten die man muss heizen
wenn wir müssen alles zusammenhalten
meine Mama braucht mich also lauter
Slogans die reinwerflich sind keinerlei
Informationsgehalt haben und uns mal
schlappe also gute 80 Millionen Euro
kosten nur diese zwei und das sind auch
die Tür es sind eben es ist
Informationen also die Informationen die
mal aus dem Hause Haarwerk aus dem
Wirtschaftsministerium heraustragen dass
das Entlüften der Heizung irgendwie sehr
viel bringt noch mal an zusätzliche
einspar Kapazität da würde ich sogar
noch sagen habe ich mir jetzt nie groß
Gedanken drüber gemacht in Gottes Namen
sagt uns das noch mal ansonsten sollen
Regierung informieren über das was sie
tun und gerne von mir aus auf einer
Seite des Wirtschaftsministeriums über
Energiesparmöglichkeiten aber sie sollen
nicht nicht Propaganda also moralisch
aufgeladene Propaganda fürs impfen und
fürs Heizung runterdrehen machen genau
das tun sie und das wird immer mehr und
meine Wahrnehmung ist es geht auch immer
mehr Leuten wahnsinnig auf die Nerven
und es korrespondiert übrigens einer
anderen Beobachtung die Journalisten
vielleicht teilen werden das nämlich das
pressesprecherwesen bei den Ministerien
und bei der beim Bundeskanzleramt
wahnsinnig zunehmen früher hatten sie in
so einem Haus einen Pressesprecher heute
haben sie vier sechs acht Pressesprecher
in den Häusern und die tun nicht das was
man so erwarten würde als Laie nämlich
dass sie dass sie den Journalisten also
Fragen beantworten und Ihnen damit
helfen ihren demokratischen Auftrag zu
erfüllen nämlich die Öffentlichkeit zu
informieren und auch zu beurteilen was
eine Regierung tut sondern die sind auf
Abwehr ausgerichtet sie kriegen keine
vernünftige Antwort mehr auf keinem Haus
ist es wirklich nur also der Sport also
Journalisten Fragen abwehren und aktiv
auf die Bürger zugehen aber eben nicht
mit mit sozusagen sachlichen Argumenten
und Informationen sondern mit moralisch
aufgeladene Agentin auch vorher Männer
behandelt die Politik manchmal die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger wie so kleine
Kinder also ich merke einen Mangel an
Empathie ganz drastisch und zum zweiten
ähm diese wartenburgmentalität ne wir
machen jetzt mal den den Wagenburg zu
die Indianer können gerne umschreiben
wir schießen zurück ne das ist er erbt
aus früheren vielleicht schon Jahrzehnte
zurückliegenden Zeiten bei den Grünen
z.B kann ich mir das gut vorstellen wo
man dachte man wäre so ein
gesellschaftlicher anderer Dock und muss
sich da irgendwie abstürmen aber das ist
wenn man regiert ist man für die ganzen
über 80 Millionen Leute zuständig ob
einem die passen oder nicht und das
stört mich sehr an dieser Regierung
diese Wagenburg wenn der natalität die
haben jetzt eine Menge Probleme gehabt
die Vorgänger Regierungen auch nicht
angepackt haben das haben sie aber
gewusst Kampagne vorher auch schon im
Bundestag und können ja Wohnhaus halt
lesen und die SPD war dabei ja und die
SPD war dabei noch schlimmer so und das
zweite ist meiner Meinung nach dass ganz
viele jetzt auch nicht genau wissen was
man machen kann aber in der Politik gilt
es ja sofort als Loser wenn du mal
zukommst dazu gibst dass du nicht genau
weiß was man jetzt als nächstes machen
muss wir sind aber jetzt alle
widerstange im Nebel unterwegs jeder von
uns ähm und ähm da müssen wir überlegen
wie man da sofort kommen das auf der
einen Seite
nicht verspricht oder nicht halten kann
auf der anderen Seite herstellt das ist
im Moment die Herausforderung an jeden
in der Regierung und da braucht man
wahrscheinlich die besten Köpfe weil das
echt schwer ist glauben Sie denn Herr
Fassbender dass man wenn solchen
Werbekampagnen wie sie Frau Gaschke
jetzt gerade angesprochen hat die zum
einen viel Steuergeld kosten aber
wirklich auch Bürger beeinflussen kann
das hat doch jeder sein eigenes Hirn und
kann sagen
öffentlich anders also stell mir gerade
vor wenn wir hier wir reden jetzt hier
fast eine Stunde über wirklich
Realitäten ja sind wir nicht alle immer
einer meiner sehen wir manchmal aus
verschiedenen Perspektiven und so weiter
weil vor allem wenn es um die Zukunft
geht wenn hier vier Politiker sehr sind
was weiß ich schöne Worte reden alle
allein schon diese Konzentration auf
Sprachregelungen ja mein Eindruck ist
die Politiker sind viel zu sehr von von
den Medien beherrscht und die machen
machen ihr Ding für die Medien nicht für
die Bürger ja die Medien sind viel
wichtiger als die Bürger vor allem so
Sprache Regelung bloß nicht das falsche
Wort sagen was hat der der Wagner
gerade erzählt hat ist es für die Medien
immer schwieriger Informationen zu
kriegen erscheint vielleicht eher so als
seien sie um ihrem Leben
die Medien heute und das Stichwort
Wagenburg das kann doch voll
unterschreiben die Medien sind dominiert
von einer bestimmten Sichtweise auf die
Welt von einer bestimmten Welt anschauen
die sie für fortschrittlich halten die
Medien haben sehr genau definiert was
rückständig ist das meistens geht um
Sprachregelungen was man was man sagen
muss und was man nicht sagen darf aber
nicht die Bild nee nee
jetzt auch mal zurück
es gibt sie doch nur es gibt sie beide
jetzt also ihre Häuser doch nur weil wir
seit einigen Jahren bereits ein
gegenläufigen Prozess Erleben der aber
auf die Politik noch nicht wirklich
zurückschlägt oder Punkt aber die
Programme entschuldigung ich lese in den
Leitmedien im sogenannten Leitmedien
immer noch die Helme darüber das Bild TV
nicht so viele Zuschauer hat wie es doch
eigentlich gerne hätte dass also wir wir
als Leitmedien unsere Dominanz weiterhin
erfolgreich verteidigen unsere Wagenburg
Medium definieren und das hat Medium
ganz genau
in Europa
ich verfolgte auf Twitter das alles ja
Diskussion meinungskorridor und und nur
einige die da so ein bisschen versuchen
dazu quer auch zu argumentieren und an
anderen Frauen aber es gibt natürlich
auch ein wahnsinnigen Binnendruck in den
parte